palanca una población rural de menos de
dos mil habitantes ha sido testigo de
uno de los mayores flujos de refugiados
en europa desde la segunda guerra
mundial dimite el alcalde lleva un mes
de frenética actividad coordinando los
puntos de entrada estancia y salida de
cientos de miles de ucranianos que han
pasado por este pequeño poblado
es un momento histórico estamos felices
de ayudar a nuestros vecinos ucranianos
pero la gente aquí está preocupada
vivimos muy cerca de la frontera y en
cualquier momento la guerra puede llegar
aquí tres organizaciones internacionales
locales y voluntarios asisten a los
recién llegados en esta improvisada
estación de autobuses con autocares con
destinos nacionales internacionales a
medida que la guerra parece acercarse al
sur de ucrania más y más y más familias
han decidido marcharse lejos sentarse en
un autobús que les llevará a un nuevo
destino
huimos de mykolaiv porque empezaron a
bombardear muy fuerte al principio no
queríamos irnos pero mis hijos estaban
aterrados
vamos a rumanía donde tengo una hermana
queremos pedir asilo a canadá
a sólo 4 kilómetros los que separan
palanca del paso fronterizo con el mismo
nombre por el cruzar a diario cientos de
vehículos mujeres niños y ancianos a pie
huyendo de la guerra rostros tristes de
mujeres pero con la mirada aliviada
porque sus hijos están ahora a salvo
aquí en el borde fronterizo de palanca
son más los que vienen que los que se
van a medida que la guerra parece
estancarse y las tropas rusas intentan
avanzar hacia el sur para poder tomar la
ciudad de odessa que está solo a 100 km
de este borde fronterizo